all right hello everyone and uh welcome
to this session
going to uh briefly speak to you about
um
omics logic
and our training that is available
that is hopefully going to be useful to
some of you that are joining uh today's
session and in general
so I'm going to get started I know that
we
um maybe have another minute or two and
you know welcome for others to join as
well but
um let me briefly introduce myself my
name is Elia Brodsky and
um I am the CEO of pine biotech one of
the co-founders of pine biotech and have
been doing a lot of uh you know
different types of activities around
bioinformatics research support
development of the T bioentricle
platform and application to different
challenges in bioinformatics and a big
and growing kind of area of our work is
related to training and education and so
today I'll talk specifically about the
training and bioinformatics and data
Science Education
and I'm also looking forward to getting
to know a little bit more about you
um and who you are now in addition to
doing this for Pine biotech I'm also an
instructor at the Georgetown
um University
uh School of Medicine where I teach a
course on machine learning in Python and
I also work together with the Louisiana
biomedical research Network and the
National Association of idea principal
investigators to bring this kind of
training online virtually across many
different universities in the network to
help Elevate the level of biomedical
research
across these universities
so here are some topics that I would
like to cover today
um first of all I'd love to talk about
the role of data in the research life
cycle so really how does that address
the issue of time and efficiency time is
the most uh valuable asset that each one
of us have has and when you think about
time in perspective of a project in
perspective of your career and in the
perspective of getting to complete a
certain valuable asset for example a
publication or a poster presentation or
maybe a grant these are very real
considerations about time and efficiency
the second topic I'd love to talk about
is to be or not to be should I become an
expert or a generalist
so I'll offer kind of my perspective on
this what I have seen across thousands
of students that we have dealt with uh
as we run the Onyx logic training and
then I'll talk a little bit about the
psychology of getting started so I think
that you know if we really look at the
issue of why is it so difficult for
people who have not had the experience
from an early age dealing with data it
becomes difficult because a big part of
it is the fear of solving irrelevant
problems and I'll talk a little bit
about that in the context of other
available types of courses that are out
there
then I'll talk about the future of your
and my academic careers uh so what are
the realistic prospects for someone who
has an expertise perhaps a deep
expertise in a particular area of
research to really succeed in the
academic career and if you don't succeed
what is Plan B how do you plan for that
and how can you prepare for something
that can be equally as rewarding and
impactful
and then finally I'll talk about
um courses lectures and training are
they really enough is it really enough
to have a certificate to show that you
have completed some training and does
that mean that you have the skill and
what does that tell uh the potential
employer the potential collaborator that
you will have about your expertise and
experience
this is the last point the last point is
about a community and the community is
really all about exchange giving and
taking
so I'll talk a little bit about how we
are trying to grow all mixed logic into
more than just a platform for learning
we're also looking forward to working
with collaborators and making sure that
this community grows organically Beyond
just uh what our company can provide
so with that these are the topics for
today I'll kind of refer back to the
slide a couple of times throughout the
presentation and I hope that if you have
any questions along the line along the
way if you have any comments any
questions feel free to add them in the
chat I will ask at some point for you to
do some practical things and maybe refer
back to the chat box so please keep that
open and keep that in mind
all right so again thank you uh and let
us uh start talking about the first
point so the role of data in research
life cycle
so
um I think traditionally we think about
two separate areas that are data
generating and interpreting or making
decisions about and I think that this
kind of a separation has really kind of
brought us to the point where we are
today
so today we really see that all of these
breakthroughs and techniques and new
technologies in
molecular biology Precision medicine
biotechnology and agriculture are
causing for there to be a gap between
data and information so what do we know
how to generate and what do we know how
to interpret and in fact this is not
just based on my perception this is
something that has been extensively
published on including this interesting
survey that talks about
how technical demands are actually
preventing Learners from acquiring these
relevant data analysis and data
interpretation skills so it starts from
this kind of conceptual separation of
the two parts where we generate data and
who analyzes and makes decisions about
the data and then we'll talk about the
specific skills that are needed because
obviously to generate data you need to
understand the wet lab you need to
understand how the samples are prepared
what is the experimental design time
what are kind of the biological
objectives that you have in mind and
then when it comes to data analysis it's
a whole another world
of algorithms and data types and
different types of data visualization
techniques and everything that goes into
interpretation so it's really another
world and because of that we have this
Gap that actually causes people to think
well you know if I want to get started
with data analysis with bioinformatics I
have a whole list of prerequisite
courses that I have to complete like
mathematics and statistics and coding
and then I have to have someone to guide
me in to help me and there's maybe
limited infrastructure on where to store
this data and how to access it and also
how do I work on data sets that are
relevant to my area of research
and not just
um you know some hello world or
marketing or Finance data that might not
be relevant to what I'm interested in
and I might find kind of boring or even
difficult to kind of try and understand
the concepts that they're working with
so to summarize I think that you know
there are specific challenges and
limitations when it comes to introducing
this kind of data science curriculum for
life science students and I think that
it has to do with incredibly Dynamic
field that bioinformatics is with a lot
of new techniques and a lot of new
software that is being developed and
updated all the time
um I think that you know typically
universities and academic institutions
limit are limited with their processing
power
and how much of that power could be
allocated to uh students there are not a
lot of curated data sets and effective
pipelines that somebody has validated so
you kind of anticipated a lot of
technical challenges when you start
analyzing data and you don't have
examples that are maybe relevant
specifically to your field I think that
students even if they are introduced to
kind of theory of bioinformatics and
data science most of it is theoretical
and they don't have a lot of practical
experience because they are placed in
projects to perform very short-term and
specific tasks so they don't have that
broad view of what goes into all of the
steps combined and then I think that you
know faculty because they have
experienced academic growth it you know
maybe in the previous few decades
themselves they don't see the need
specific to the students challenges that
they face they don't really kind of
appreciate how effective it could be if
students were exposed to these specific
types of skills that are needed and are
not kind of systematically thinking
about how to address that challenge
so what we are trying to do is to
address some of these challenges through
these three elements
standardization organization and
systematization so what does that really
mean I hope that in the next few slides
I'll be able to kind of expand on all of
these but in a nutshell it means that
the curriculum needs to be standardized
and it needs to be kind of the same
thing whether you are studying
Neuroscience or you're studying
agriculture two very different fields
but both of them require the data
analysis skill sets and tools to be able
to make decisions about the data that
they generate
organization I think that there are a
lot of online tutorials little Snippets
of code here and there some Publications
about pipelines but no one's really put
the effort to organize this in a way
that anyone can go from a very beginner
level and kind of advance to a more
expert level in a way that is
predictable uh kind of uh clear and has
validated points of progression
and then finally systematization so
systematization means that now this
package can actually be turned into a
system so it's a package of online
tutorials a package of pipelines that
you can run code and exercises that you
can complete and projects that you can
develop and that system is really what
uh Onyx logic is all about
so we talked briefly about the role of
data in the research life cycle about
time and efficiency we talked about the
gap between those that generate data and
those that analyze data we talked about
to be or not to be should I become an
expert or be a generalist I think the
answer clearly is that you should be
both you should be an expert in one
field but you should also have the
general understanding of Trends in this
important field uh where we are and
finally let's talk about the psychology
of getting started overcoming the fear
of solving irrelevant problems so what
is that fear
probably you have tried at some point in
your career or life something new and it
always starts with this mock example
that has nothing to do with what you are
interested in and so that's what I want
to talk about about how you can kind of
slip that and start from where you
already are maybe in a field that you're
interested in and then from there
identify the gaps that prevent you from
acquiring the skills that you need to be
not only kind of superficially aware of
the challenges but also being able to
solve and overcome those challenges so
then after that we'll talk about the
future academic career what are some
limitations maybe challenges and some
opportunities for those that do have the
skills and can validate that they have
the experience or expertise and uh about
you know how we can kind of view
coursework as just a starting point and
then what else is needed to be enough to
have enough experience and to know that
you can apply these skills not just you
know kind of know about them and then
finally I'll finish with our community
what is this community who's a member of
this community how can you become this
member a member of this community either
as a faculty or as a student so let's
talk about the psychology of getting
started how to overcome the fear of
solving irrelevant problems so according
to the Bloom's taxonomy of learning
learning is a process that has very
specific kind of layers that go from
just the basics understanding
terminology remembering terms
um and kind of that's where it starts so
for example in my own experience when I
started dealing with interacting with a
lot of biologists I remember quite a
number of conversations where it seemed
like I have to have a dictionary to
interpret what they are saying it was
about genes it was about proteins I
remember I had a conversation with a
clinician that was talking about
different cancer immunotherapies and
literally every word in a sentence I
needed to interpret and so I think that
you know even if you don't understand
all of the terms you need to be familiar
with them to be able to string together
there what is the actual meaning of this
sentence or of this topic and from there
of course you need to start explaining
ideas and Concepts so we'll talk a
little bit about how the same applies to
data when a biologist speaks to a data
scientist for example I think the
situation is very similar you kind of
listen and all of it is about you know
different technical details and terms
that maybe they are so familiar with
that they feel like everybody should
understand but you feel like you
actually don't know anything what
they're talking about and so that's
really the foundational layers when you
start to kind of recognize and
understand some of these terms and the
meaning of them becomes clear
then you can use this information in new
situations right so next time when you
go and you read an article a publication
on the topic that you're interested in
instead of skipping the method section
you actually read through and you re
recognize those same terms that you just
learned and you understand how they are
applied in that particular context
so then you all of a sudden start seeing
that everybody's using these terms
everybody's talking about the same kind
of processes about data cleaning about
processing about kind of visualizing
this data about statistical methods to
confirm their hypothesis and things like
that and then finally you kind of go on
to the peak of this pyramid which makes
you independent and that Independence
and that ability to apply what you have
learned to completely new situations
leads you to the ability to produce new
or original work
so with this in mind let us get started
so now I would like you to all uh take
that leap of faith and come with me to
the omics logic portal where you will
find uh all that you need to get started
with this process so in the chat box uh
thank you Jesse for sharing that link
there's a link to the portal which is
called omnix logic biology as a data
science
so to get started all you need to do is
to sign up so when you get to this link
you click on login
and you can create an account using your
social media accounts or email so I'll
give just a couple of minutes for anyone
who would like to sign up right now and
I will sign in in the meantime so that
we can go through and we'll use a couple
of practical exercises from this portal
to give you a sense of what is this all
about and how does it work so please
take a moment to sign up
after you sign up you will be redirected
to the courses page
and when you are on the courses page you
should be able to see your email address
or your name right here
and so the next thing that we're going
to do is we're going to go to that
profile page so again I'm going to give
this just a couple more minutes for
anyone who would like to sign up today
and once you do sign up please let me
know you can simply put done or yes or
number one or something like that in the
chat box so that I know that you have uh
signed up and you're ready to go on
all right thank you marinel Sanja
yes and if you already have a profile
then uh you're good to go but we're just
going to give it
um one more minute for anyone else who
would like to
all right great so
thank you
um so when you arrive on this page what
you will see is that you have a profile
that you can complete so as you can see
my profile is 100 complete so the first
thing to do I think is to call this
place your own
um okay so if you have an issue signing
up uh maybe you can share your email
address or team is here in the chat and
they can maybe help you with that as
well
so
okay thank you
um so once you sign up and you complete
your profile it helps you kind of
connect what you are doing to
um a profile that you can share and
we'll go through a few of these but I'll
kind of show you around what goes into
completing your profile uh obviously
your full name accurately capitalized
some kind of a picture it doesn't have
to be your profile it can also be a logo
from your University social media
accounts or orc ID where you can connect
to your academic Publications and the
way you edit all of these is by clicking
on this profile button and here you can
see all of this information that you can
update and edit now as you go through
the different exercises that we have you
will see that there are points
achievements and certificates that you
are able to achieve you'll have the
option to get a subscription so today
anyone for free can do the exercises
that we are going to do but if you would
like to go beyond that there is a basic
subscription just at ten dollars a month
and then you will also see how you can
participate in programs where a mentor
will guide you through more and more
advanced topics that you might want to
know how to learn
so all of that information is going to
be also in these tabs here you have
courses uh programs that you are a part
of certificates that you have obtained
and once you have a certain number of
prog a certain number of points you will
also be able to develop a project of
your own which I will get to in just a
couple more minutes
so this portal allows you to access our
community
Beyond just the portal itself we have a
LinkedIn group with over 2 000
Professionals in the field of
bioinformatics and machine learning and
data science a community of about 10 000
people on Facebook and you will also
join kind of our community on slack
where we discuss different topics
related to this field so as I mentioned
you want to start by completing your
profile that's where you will see your
activity and validate your achievement
in the form of certificates and the next
place that you want to go to is the
course tab so under the courses you will
be able to look up specific topics that
are most interesting and relevant to you
so here you will find a search bar where
you can just search with any text you
will also find some topics that are kind
of used as tags for the different
resources that we have on the T bioinfo
platform transcriptomics project
examples bioinformatics and others and
down below you will have collections so
the first collection that I want to
introduce you to today is called this
getting started collection so it's right
here getting started and that's what
that logo looks like
the getting started collection is
something that we developed as a free
resource for anyone who would like to
jump into this field of bioinformatics
and it starts off with a very brief
course called introduction to
bioinformatics the introduction to
bioinformatics course covers the very
basic ideas about how bioinformatics has
impacted Fields like Precision medicine
uh you know space
study and others and gives you a view of
the challenges that big data in this
field introduce the next course is
called bytes and molecules again it's a
free course that you can complete and
get a certificate for if you just signed
up and this course offers a view of the
basic terminology what are genes and
what are bytes what are data Concepts
that you need to know how do these
things fit together and kind of what are
the specific Concepts that you need to
understand
it also gives you a view of how
different coding languages like R and
python are used to actually work with
this data more effectively it's not like
you cannot you know look at sequences of
genes in a notepad or write them out or
print them out right the first genome is
actually a collection of books that you
can store on the library but to be more
effective with these kinds of data it is
very useful to be able to work with
these object oriented languages that
also have a lot of useful packages that
you probably know about
that generate publication-ready visuals
that you can use and also produce easy
to use statistical analyzes and machine
learning methods so the Bison molecules
course covers some important aspects
that I think anyone would benefit from
reviewing and refreshing in their minds
before you jump into the next series of
courses now what we typically recommend
is after you complete this that course
is to go through some of the additional
coursework that is aligned with your
interest so that means you look up not
just skills like Python and R but you
actually focus on the types of
applications or data sets that you might
want to work with for example Ebola
virus cancer or maybe Neuroscience like
Alzheimer's disease
so to summarize the omics logic basic
curriculum includes training on
introduction to bioinformatics and data
sets like genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics and an
additional set of training courses on
the basics of data science coding
statistical analysis and machine
learning in application to biomedical
data now
the important part of it is that we
prioritize this approach of code or no
code bioinformatics and I think that's
very important because as I mentioned
there's a psychological barrier that
prevents many people to get started
because they anticipate the difficulties
of actually learning the basics of
coding math or some kind of a portion of
this that just prevents them from
getting started so we want to eliminate
that all together and that's why we have
a series of courses that you can
complete on all of these topics without
coding at all and that helps you
understand the logic of analysis and the
application of these analyzes to Big
Data which oftentimes is not even
possible on your own computer
the second part is well what happens
behind the scenes and behind the scenes
you will see that each one of these
steps is actually a series of algorithms
or scripts that string together
different analysis topics so that you
can actually perform the analysis from
beginning to the end
a large part of that
when you become more independent with
these tools is to be able to start
asking your own questions of data and
that means a lot of data manipulation
data wrangling visualizations
statistical analysis Etc that you have
to know how to do and that's why we
provide an extensive training on data
science in R and Python and then finally
as I mentioned we have a community
community of experts that teach that
share project examples and that talk
about The Cutting Edge analyzes that are
needed in the space where the challenges
and opportunities are for anyone and
they also we turn that into a collection
of resources that anyone can use once
they are part of this community so let
me briefly introduce you to how
practically does this work so the first
example is going to be from the T violin
platform where I will show you how you
can play around with data so what we'll
look at is a series of of visual outputs
that you can play around with to
understand what this data means so how
to go from analysis to interpretation
and then I will take you through a brief
exercise where you will see how you can
get started with coding which means
solving coding challenges
understanding code syntax and being able
to take that code and use it on your own
computer or in your own cloud
environment
to do that let's go to
the T bioinfo platform
okay which is a separate portal to the
omics logic portal but after you have
signed up you will get a
um you will get
um credentials to log in here thank you
Jesse
so you have the link to this portal in
the chat
and as you kind of get started with
bioinformatics one of the objectives is
to understand a whole variety of
possible analytical approaches to
different data types so that's why this
areas of analysis section is organized
by data type you can see here next
Generation sequencing data Mass
spectrometry structural biology data
integration and modeling and here you
will find some additional sections as
well like virology single cell analysis
cancer biology and metagenomics as well
so it's really a comprehensive platform
that is organized driven by Logic of
analysis that provides us with some
practical tools that you can use for
research
guided tutorials that you can follow and
also interactive dashboards that you can
use to kind of see the relationship
between the data and the biology that
you are studying so to do that let us go
to the transcriptomics section right
here we're going to go first to the bulk
rna-seq example
if you click on the drop down you will
find several demo pipelines that are
essentially projects that you will also
find on the omics logic portal and here
what we can do is we can take this
second project called PDX
this is a project on breast cancer and
I'll just use it as an illustration of
how this platform Works in application
to teaching and then what kind of data
exploration you can actually get as a
result of Performing this demo analysis
so as you will find each step of the way
includes logical explanations of the
steps without being focused necessarily
on the technical terms for example in
each one of these steps pre-processing
mapping and quantification a number of
alternative algorithms can be used
all of these alternative algorithms
perform the same function premium
processing mapping or quantification and
so you will see that each one of these
steps is color coded to reflect the
function of that algorithm
when you click on OK you will then be
given a limited number of suggestions so
you don't have to search around and
think you know how do I connect this
step to the next it automatically
suggests what is the best next step for
you to do
so here you have an explanation of this
particular step which is to clean up the
reads and make sure that the read
quality before you start processing it
Downstream is good here you have an
explanation of why these technical
artifacts might arise
then we will click to mapping on
transcripts where we have to map reads
to a particular region on the genome
and then we will quantify how high of an
expression do we have for a particular
Gene so for example if I want to compare
two conditions I would like to arrive at
differential Expressions so here we have
the differential expression where we
will look at some statistical measures
that can tell us which Gene is actually
responsible for the differentiation
between two different conditions and
then finally we will click on end
and here we will look at some outputs
that you can go through and quickly
recognize probably uh so that you
understand what is for example the
output of trimatic you know how do we
evaluate the sequence quality of these
reads and what is actually being trimmed
so here you can see the multi-qc report
and then you can also check for example
the level of expression how does that
expression vary by the different samples
that we have here so you can see that
fairly comparable to each other so we
can proceed and then finally let's go to
this link which is a dashboard now this
dashboard combines together several of
the analysis results
so that we can start looking at the
connection between the data and the
interpretation that we are trying to
make so here we can you know change
different parameters that we have uh we
can adjust uh things and we can kind of
explore the different aspects of this
data set to really try to link it to the
biology that we know and understand
okay so here we changed the color scheme
and here we also see on the volcano plot
how individual genes that are
responsible for the difference between
these two conditions are annotated so we
have the original Gene ID we have the
gene name and we also have the common
name so we understand what this Gene
does
now of course this is useful right so
for example here I can add a couple of
other genes and kind of see what they
mean and all of a sudden I recognize oh
there's a gene here that I know
something about egfr and egfr seems to
be highly expressed in group two and not
expressed in group one so I can start
making interpretations about what I see
in this data now this is nice because I
can play around with things
but it's also good to have this data on
hand and so here you can download all of
this data together
uh here's another project like this this
is a project about
um the differential and gene expression
results for an Alzheimer's study where
we have two conditions and we want to
identify the top differentially
expressed genes between these two
conditions so people who do not have
Alzheimer's disease and people that do
have Alzheimer's disease and we have a
clear summary here of how these
particular patients vary and you can
also see here the different genes that
might be responsible for that and you
can kind of compare two different genes
for example that are up and down
regulated in these different groups
another example that I have here is a
metagenomics data analysis so again a
different type of data not rna-seq but
describing the microbial Community but
what I can see in this microbial
Community if I look over here is that
there are different ways that I can
actually analyze this kind of data there
are many different types of metadata
annotations for each one of my samples
and there are many different types of
metrics that I can use to compare and
contrast the different groups in my data
sets so this is just a preview of how
very quickly you can start looking at
data using annotation understanding the
major differences between the data sets
that you are analyzing and kind of get
familiar with what might be a standard
visualization that you will find in
Publications
let's take a look now at the second
example so let's say we understand
conceptually what is being done how can
we use that conceptual understanding to
actually start learning how to code and
analyze this data on our own
so to do that we will go back to the
omics logic portal and let us go to the
course of this tab
on the courses tab we will start with
introduction to bioinformatics
in r
getting started with bioinformatics
so getting started with bioinformatics
is a course that you can complete
independently in probably under
um you know a couple of hours but what
it gives you is a preview of how you go
from kind of looking at charts like this
to understanding the concepts behind
them and eventually being able to
practice them independently
so we just saw the result of this uh
pipeline that basically showed us the
rna-seq gene expression profiles across
several different samples right so we
saw something like this where we have a
lot of samples and they have a
distribution and we can use that
distribution to compare them to each
other and so one of the plots that we
were just looking at is a histogram or a
bar plot for example and so in this
example you can actually start
practicing this code on your own
the console is built right into the
lesson so all you have to do is follow
the examples and replicate the syntax
that was given to you
so here for example you already have a
full script that you can simply run but
you can see that there are portions of
this code that are missing and so the
challenges that you will see is how to
complete this syntax in a way that you
know it actually works and so to do this
we need to write in read
so here I'm loading the data by reading
this table that is on this link and you
can see that it has row names and a
header and so here I will add true
okay and now I get another
um
issue another problem and you can see
that true is actually not spelled
correctly so what I need to do is I need
to
make it true like this so I'm learning
the syntax as I am trying to run this
analysis so let's clear that output okay
now you can see there's again a problem
so there's something missing here
there's not an X
um argument so here I need to say is
Matrix DF
and finally I am successful right so the
process of learning actually happens
through troubleshooting the errors that
I am getting right and so what I'm
learning about this is how the code is
organized how can I just try and run it
and see what happens and when it happens
I actually see the problem and once I
see the problem I can address the coding
issue that I am facing so in a similar
way
you can now address the second problem
that we have again you will find all the
same kind of ideas where you have uh
different uh kind of missing pieces that
you would have to fill in
um and as a result uh you can kind of
read through the errors and try to see
whether you can find what is the air and
what exactly is the problem that you
know I am facing so here again the same
idea you kind of go through each one of
these steps complete them and after you
are done you can actually see your
progress in your profile now in addition
to that you can see everybody's progress
and you will see that this is not just a
platform that you know we use you and I
but you can see here how maybe every
minute there's someone who is doing some
kind of an assignment completing some
kind of of a course signing up you know
completing quizzes and and other types
of activities that we are just looking
at together so really this is uh just a
way to get started
um and join a full community of people
that are on the same path to learning
about data science and bioinformatics
so as you will see a lot of different
options uh options to start playing with
data and kind of trying to think about
what it means and options to start
playing with code where you can start
looking at how to fix syntax how to run
a particular script and even how to take
that script and use it further in your
own research by knowing how to load data
how to visualize data how to sorry
perform statistical analysis how to do
data wrangling and eventually also how
to perform complex machine learning
algorithms and apply those models to
your own data sets
so it's great right but is this kind of
an approach enough so this is a picture
of me a few years ago when I received a
certificate for completing an online
course and you know today I have maybe
uh tens of these certificates of courses
that I completed on data science and
business and finance and all these other
topics does that make me an expert so
indeed there are lectures that we go and
see YouTube videos online tutorials
Coursera edx udemy and continuous
education but do these show that we know
what we are doing and do they actually
give some validity to the skills that we
say that we have
my uh conclusion from going through
these courses myself and working with
many others that have completed this
kind of training also is that so many
times it is not enough to show that you
understand a topic or have that skill
and that's why I think the portfolio
approach here makes a lot more sense
GitHub kaggle LinkedIn
research posters at conferences
Publications those are things that
actually add validity to us knowing how
to do something what can you see in a
project well in a project you can
actually see that you've understood the
problem or you have yourself kind of
created a question about a particular
problem you have been able to overcome
challenges troubleshoot you know revise
uh understand how this process of
analysis works right so you've put in
the effort and then finally it's your
presentation as well either it is
written presentation visual presentation
or live presentation like I'm doing
today you know you have to validate that
you can showcase explain answer
questions and be able to support your
statements with evidence so though those
are the things that actually help us
gain that experience but also help us
show that we possess the skills that we
say we have and that is why
this omix logic portal is not just about
training skills it also has project
examples and curated data sets in the
field of oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and Agriculture and these
topics are actually the beginning of
taking that initial kind of training to
the next level and that next level is
creating an independent Project based on
a topic that you understand you care
about and you know how to present to
others
to do that
on your profile after you complete your
profile right and we just kind of saw
how completing the profile happens you
have to upload your image you have to um
you know add your bio you have to
connect your social media links right
all of these steps help you create a
profile and after you create that
profile you can see that the next step
is to gain 10 000 points so to gain ten
thousand points you will have to go
through courses and training to actually
perform the exercises and then finally
there's a course that will introduce you
to the basic idea of how to actually uh
do a project in bioinformatics and after
you've completed those steps you will be
able to start working on an independent
project which is like preparing for a
publication so you actually take a
project title you know so start kind of
looking at specific data sets and maybe
doing literature review and going
through steps of actually preparing a
full
um kind of an overview
with a uh presentation of your analysis
results that you can then add into this
project of your own now it includes
addressing some very important
challenges in this field of
bioinformatics like for example
reproducibility being able to provide
you know exactly which data set did you
actually use for this study or did you
curate the data in any way and maybe
took just a portion of the data or
cleaned it up in a certain way right so
all of these things are covered in that
section now instead of just listening to
me talk about it I would like to share
with you some of the projects that some
of the people on our portal have
completed and then Muhammad I will
actually get to your question there in
the chat as well so here is a link where
you can see all the different projects
that students who have gone through this
training have completed you can look at
this project and kind of see uh you know
all of the different steps that we just
described so where are the data sets
that you can actually download an
abstract an introduction a methodology
what was done in this project which
pipelines they have used what do these
results look like right so similar to
kind of what we saw in those dashboards
Etc and you can really go through all of
these steps and importantly you can
react to them you can support the person
who did that project by liking
commenting or even sharing that project
um with with others on social media
so again take a look at some of these
projects you will find that these are
all students who came from a life
science background they quickly learned
about these new topics like processing
analysis and visualization of this data
and we're able in a short period of time
to create a project and present it to
mentors for feedback
now when I say mentors what I mean is we
have a an independent process where you
can do this completely on your own just
following the steps that I described or
if you would like to do it faster you
can work with our mentors to actually
help you select the topic address
technical challenges and review and
provide you with feedback on the final
product and that is where programs come
in so if you go into the programs tab
you will see here Mentor guided programs
on different topics including what we
call a research Fellowship so the
research Fellowship is really a three or
six months process
when you work with an expert Mentor who
has a bioinformatics or a data science
background and can introduce you to
additional mentors on the topic of your
choice like oncology Neuroscience
biotechnology and others and so the
process starts by a little bit of
training depending on what level of
training you already have introduction
to the different types of data sets that
are out there and then eventually being
able to work through those data sets to
create a project of your own
so let me um also give you a brief
overview of some of these mental guided
programs so that you understand how
these Mentor guided programs are
different from asynchronous independent
courses that we just looked at and then
I will finish off with how these
programs fit in with the research
fellowship and the community of experts
that you can leverage to prepare your
portfolio of projects either to advance
your academic career or explore careers
in the industry
one of the challenges for many
um people coming from a life science
background is to understand that a lot
of these analyzes
divide into specific challenges of that
particular data type and general skills
that are needed across the board and so
a good example is transcriptomics where
we have
just what we saw the standard approach
to analysis uh kind of standard
statistical analysis and machine
learning of complex rna-seq or gene
expression data and in this program we
cover all of these sections by going
through the logic of the analysis and
then after we understand the logic of
the analysis understanding how this
varies whether we analyze bulk or single
cell rna-seq data uh we understand demo
pipelines where we kind of string
together individual steps into a logical
flow and each one of those steps has a
specific role that allows you to
understand how these steps are connected
to produce a result that you can
interpret and then you're introduced to
projects where you can focus on analysis
of such uh rna-seq data in cancer in
Neuroscience infectious diseases or even
agriculture
now as you all know the single cell data
is becoming more and more available and
so the question is how do you actually
take this kind of data analyze it
understanding all of the steps and so we
have created pipelines that kind of
organize all of this information in a
simple to use way so that it is
reproducible and clear what the logic of
the analysis was and then as we already
saw you have these dashboards that come
alongside the standard scripts that are
going to be used in R and python to
perform this analysis independently but
also to be able to apply standard tools
to different data sets for data
visualization and your presentations so
you will have access to interactive
notebooks to kind of complete that on
your own
finally you will be introduced to
project examples these project examples
illustrate how these challenges have
been addressed by experts on what types
of data sets and leading to what kind of
interpretable results
so these types of programs are data
specific another set of programs are
application specific like bioinformatics
for infectious diseases where we
actually take applications of
bioinformatics to different types of
infectious diseases that are either
viral or bacterial in nature to
understand the process of pathogenesis
and also the interaction between the
host and the pathogen so there we take
examples from different types of
diseases like malaria tuberculosis coven
and others and we learn about these
approaches that are commonly used for
Diagnostic purposes as well as to
understand the basic biology and design
interventions so here we have a set of
projects that we have prepared together
with our collaborators like the
enterovirus outbreak evd68 malaria
infection in Ghana SARS Cove 2 genomics
around the world and the Ebola virus
pandemic throughout the uh throughout
the West African outbreak not so long
ago so what's important here is that you
are going to understand the basic
approaches but you will also be
introduced to specific types of analyzes
that can be used for practical
applications for example generating a
variant report so we take a report from
a company Cosmos ID and we replicate all
of the steps of this report in our
studio to have the exact same output and
all of the code associated with it
but we also go beyond the sequence
analysis where we start going from
sequence to structure
how do we actually superimpose this
variation at the sequence level to be
able to understand the value of having a
protein structure that helps us
interpret the interaction between the
host and the pathogen or the immune
response that we observe in the body
now finally we have a comprehensive set
of resources for training in data
science and this is actually a course
that I also teach at Georgetown
University using these resources and I
find them extremely valuable for the
students that want to go and work in the
medical field biomedical research and
biotech company so I'll talk about that
in just a few more minutes we already
saw getting started with r and python
where you can get started with code and
learn how this code applies to different
types of data we saw rna-seq data or we
can look at sequencing data the code
itself is explained in chunks
then you are given exercises to perform
visualization and you also see the
application of this approach to
different types of challenges
metagenomics transcriptomics and others
so this course can be taken in r or in
Python and it covers these standard
topics like data wrangling machine
learning supervising and unsupervised
learning feature selection signature
patterns regression deep learning and
others and uh kind of separate from the
other types of courses that we've had
this one is also focused on going
through these practical coding
challenges and generating a number of
notebooks that you can use as your own
repository of projects that you have
completed and these projects are
something that you can run and kind of
know the analysis yourself but also
anyone else can try on their own so this
is
um
you know these are just some topics that
we cover in this program that I think
are very relevant as we have more and
more complex data sets that you have to
analyze
um and that goes from kind of a high
level overview to more detailed
um kind of understanding of methods that
I think are important for anyone who is
going into this field so it's not just
high level superficial information but
actually detailed connection between the
methods the way to use those methods and
project examples where you can apply
these methods in a meaningful way and so
the way that these projects are designed
is that we take all of these Concepts
that I just went through and we actually
use uh specific Publications that
reference these key terms like here you
can see an abstract from a paper that we
actually use in the exercises and these
papers lead to an understanding of how
these methods are being being used by
experts
let me finally summarize this with who
um and how these programs are organized
and and what are the practical outcomes
that I see
so typically a program consists of three
steps first we understand the context
then we learn about bioinformatics
methods and then you have a series of
Exemplar projects that you can choose
from so that you can get started on a
project of your own
and so the full process is when we start
from basic training to then get into
more and more expert
um kind of areas which we have guest
lectures that are going to speak about
those uh topics and then you are
prepared to work on a project of your
own that results in a showcase so we've
been doing these uh you know programs
with a number of organizations and
universities around the world uh here in
Louisiana we are working with the
Louisiana State University and the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
we've worked with and we continue to
work with Georgetown University Medical
School and we work with International
universities like image University in
India one of the largest private
University Systems in India and because
we work with a lot of these
collaborators and academic partners
we have now developed a network of
experts that regularly contribute to
expanding resources and topics that we
cover we have a bi-annual event that we
have that we call the Onyx research
Symposium where members of University of
Haifa have presented as well and they
come from esteemed other kinds of uh you
know
places to really talk about The Cutting
Edge where is this whole field going and
how is it being used in a variety of
um
Fields uh now I promise to tell you a
little bit about alternatives to the
academic pathway I think for academic
Pathways we've worked with many students
who have applied bioinformatics to
research problems
but sometimes that career can have
challenges you might not find the right
Mentor you might not be able to do a
postdoc multiple times and most likely
you will not get a tenure at least for a
lot of people that does not happen so
what is the alternative well I think the
alternative is to focus on transferable
skills that are needed in research but
also valued in the industry and so we
have recently started uh kind of looking
into the specific
uh industry related skills and projects
that would help our students kind of
develop a portfolio of projects and find
a job that they can feel that they can
contribute to so on our portal you will
also find a listing of jobs starting
from internship jobs all the way to more
advanced industry jobs for more senior
professionals
and finally I want to tell you about an
upcoming event that our team has
organized
uh the microbiome in health and wellness
hackathon this is especially relevant to
those who are innovators those that want
to leverage the techniques and
technologies that we talked about today
from computer science and biotechnology
but add a portion of business to it as
well
so the hackathon and or just if you
could share the link to the hackathon as
well is going to be focused on these
three topics so it's pre-clinical
microbiome in obesity and nutrition
skin aging and beauty and pregnancy and
femtech the way this will work is that a
team of at least three students should
participate to take on one of these
challenges and develop a minimal viable
product so you will see all of the
details about the microbiome hackathon
on that link and we welcome you to
register we have some guest lectures
that you will be exposed to every aspect
of this process and the upcoming lecture
is
um coming up
so here below you can see uh all of the
lectures and I think the upcoming
lecture is actually later today uh so
Jesse maybe you could share the details
to
um on how to register to that upcoming
lecture I think the way that you would
do that is by filling out this form
below to get more information about this
upcoming lecture
so I know that I've taken a little bit
more time than I wanted to but let me uh
go back to my original slide and finish
off with this so today we talked about
the role of data in the research life
cycle time and efficiency there's more
data less people to analyze this data
and the way to maximize efficiency is to
have people that can handle both
to be or not to be should I become an
expert or be a generalist I think the
answer is that you have to be an expert
in something but you also have to be a
generalist when it comes to data you
have to understand many different types
of challenges many different types of
approaches to those challenges and many
different data types
the psychology of getting started I hope
that I alleviated the fear of solving
irrelevant Problems by showing you how
you can get started by doing all of the
things that you need understanding the
logic of analysis learning how to encode
and applying those skills to a project
that you care about
then we talked about academic careers is
there a future or are there some
Alternatives and so we are going to uh
you will see how there are opportunities
both in Academia and in industry and
having those transferable skills is key
our courses lectures and training not
enough so we talked about the portfolio
approach how instead of showing
certificates and courses that you have
completed you focus on completing
projects that show what you know and how
you did it and then finally we talked
about our growing Community where you
can both give and take and so with that
I want to welcome all of you to register
participate in all the events in the
online portal that I just demonstrated
but also to contribute so if you would
like to be a trainer you would like to
contribute a project example or work
with us to develop better solutions to
address these challenges I welcome you
to contact us
so I'm going to share my email address
all right thank you sparse and um anyone
else who would like to connect with our
team we also have a marketing team some
of them are here uh Spar star
ojasvi duta and
ayushi are all here so our contact
information is here and we're looking
forward to interacting with you further
after today's session to learn more
about your background and your interest
in what we presented today
so let me stop the sharing and uh if
anyone has any uh questions I will stay
here for the next few minutes and try to
answer those
and I don't know if uh Julia you would
like to add anything to what I just
described
you're on mute
you're on me yeah
now let me hold on one second yeah
hi Elia thank you very much for uh for
your talk uh unfortunately for uh just
uh for everybody joining from Israel and
there was a bit of a confusion we had a
change of time so uh maybe some of the
people joining from Israel just joined
now
but hopefully this session was recorded
so maybe you can also share a link
uh where it was recorded So that uh you
know whoever missed it like myself
uh could watch it again and see all the
great uh information out there
so thank you
all right great yeah sorry about the
confusion so here's the link the link is
in the chat thank you Justin for sharing
that and if you do have any questions
you have our contact information here in
the chat as well and we're happy to talk
to you more about any of these topics
that we covered today
so thank you everyone and have a good
rest of your day
thank you very much